Transportation secretary Pete Budaj
jedge he decided to do his job for a
little bit he took a break from the the
breastfeeding and the paternity leave
and Mr
budajudge has gone on TV to say that we
have got to shift to electric cars
because the electric cars are coming
it's going to happen whether you want it
or not whether we had do anything or not
cars are going to become electric so get
on board that concern in terms of the
transition and who would suffer during
that transition uh what's your response
to
that well it's absolutely right look I I
come from Southbend Indiana it's the
home of UAW Local 5 and UAW Local 9 I
saw how the past generation of of Union
auto jobs helped build the middle class
and and build communities like the one
that I grew up in uh I also saw what
happen when uh uh when those factories
closed uh what the UAW is trying to do
right now is to make sure that this next
chapter of of the Auto industry which
lets be very clear uh these cars are
going electric with without us look
they're going electric and so the the
union workers who are protesting because
all these mandates mostly climate change
BS mandates from the Biden
Administration to stop building normal
cars and shift everything often with
government subsidies to this electric
stuff that many people don't really want
uh it's just going to happen it's just
happening okay so you got to just get on
board with
it I don't really care about PE to Jed
or the cars or what's going on in the
the strike
here this story to me is about all of
the progressive technocrat project
Progressive technocrats thrive on
depoliticizing human beings what they
thrive on is oh look it's going to
happen it's just going to happen you
have no say over it you have no say over
your own life you know you can do you
can cry and you can whine and you can
vote and you can organize politically
but it doesn't matter it's happening cuz
progress demands it progress with a
capital P
demands my very very specific political
program that the Biden Administration is
spending a lot of money in power to
enforce it's obviously not true if it
were true the Biden Administration
wouldn't need to mandate all this stuff
if it's just going to happen naturally
they wouldn't need to spend so much
political capital and and actual Capital
money to push this it is electric
vehicles are spreading now because of a
particular government focus and because
because that's what they want and okay
but maybe some of us don't want that
maybe some striking workers don't want
that maybe some ordinary citizens don't
want that and maybe we're going to voice
our opinion and even if Pete Budaj
insists that history and progress of the
capital age and a capital P demand that
we get rid of our gas guzzling cars
maybe we want to keep them and so what
what are we going to do then well what
the progressives do then what the
liberals do then is they say well you
don't have a right to say
that you don't have a
right and what we respond is well we
this is government of the People by the
people for the people what do you mean I
can't set my own environmental standards
and my own manufacturing standards they
say no no this is a liberal
democracy meaning we're going to do
liberalism and when the Democracy goes
along with that we're going to celebrate
when the Democracy opposes liberalism
we're going to tell that democ Ry to
shut
up it's a it's a constant process of
depoliticization even beyond what Buddha
Jed just talking about here you see this
in the constant pointing to science when
when the Liberals and the progressives
and the technocrats they say no the
science says that we have to do this
this and that it's not me it's not my
political desire it's not people
debating how to live together coming
from perhaps different first principles
and different CH trains of thought no no
no it's just the science says that the
history says that the textbooks says
that the computer says that the progress
says that so you got to do it and you
lose your political rights right now
head on over to ramp.com
are you looking for a better way to
simplify your business finances across
expenses vendor payments and accounting
if so ramp could be a complete
GameChanger for your business ramp is a
corporate card and expense management
software designed to help you save time
and money with ramp you can issue cards
to every employee with limits and
restrictions and automate expense report
ing so you can stop wasting time at the
end of every month ramps accounting
software automatically collects receipts
and categorizes your expenses in real
time so you don't have to the time that
you will save each month on employee
expenses will allow you to close your
books eight times faster businesses that
use ramp save an average of 3.5% within
the first year ramp is easy to use get
started in less than 15 minutes whether
you have five employees or 5,000 right
now get
$250 when you join ramp just go to
ramp.com
KW that is
rm.com
cards issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic
Bank members FDIC terms and conditions
apply right now go to medishare.com as a
dailywire listener you are not only
informed you're handsome and pretty
you're also engaged and value your
freedom and responsibility that is why
we think that you will like medish share
Med share is a community- based approach
to healthcare that lines up with the
principles you believe in your values
matter and with Medishare your
Healthcare dollars won't be used for
medical procedures that don't line up
with your beliefs Medishare is the
highest rated Healthcare sharing
Ministry with a 30-year proven track
record it's not health insurance it's a
community of 400,000 Believers committed
to caring and sharing with one another
members save up to 50% 50% or more on
their monthly healthcare costs for
limited time daily wire listeners will
receive a $150 gift card when you join
Medishare to find out more go to
medishare.com
melm a l that is medishare.com
micel terms and conditions apply make
sure you head on over right now so a
dailywire listener will receive $150 in
a gift card at
medishare.com
Michel Bob Menendez still under Fire a
lot of people calling on him to resign
but oddly enough not not very many
Republicans calling on Menendez to
design and to resign rather and mediaite
has this headline mediaite says why are
no Senate Republicans calling for
Menendez to
resign Senate Republicans Democrats have
all attacked him call called on him to
step down but the Republicans won't do
it what's that about why won't they do
it two reasons one because the doj is
corrupt and the the corrupt doj has been
weaponized against Republicans in recent
years so we are just generally more
willing to give the accused the benefit
of the doubt than Democrats are when it
comes to the doj but that said Menendez
is obviously corrupt and we've all known
it for a decade so why why won't the
Republicans call on him to resign the
simple answer is because the longer this
drags out the longer Menendez holds on
to that seat the better chance a
republican has of replacing Menendez
once the seat eventually and inevitably
opens up so Menendez is holding on
because he wants to get a sweetheart
deal so he doesn't spend the rest of his
life in
prison Democrats are clamoring for him
to resign because they don't want this
continued Scandal and they don't want to
lose the seat and Republicans we're just
going to sit back and watch the show I
guess that's that's the moment of
politics that we're in right now is just
sort of sitting back and watching the
show because there's not very much that
we can do to alter the course of events
in
politics I don't think there's very much
that we can do in the 2024 presidential
primary I think it just is what it is
and and it has been for 14 months and I
don't think there's much we can do with
Mendez he's going to resign or he's not
going to resign but if we if we at least
don't push him to resign then this
Scandal is going to drag on and
Republicans can win in New Jersey we
have won in New Jersey even Chris
Christie managed to get himself elected
and we might be looking at a Republican
senator so keep it up Mr Mendez we you
are innocent until proven guilty boy
what a great clip that was
now make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the mic NS show channel
we'll see you next time